what we're looking at here is not so
simple as a matter of freedom versus
tyranny
freedom and tyranny play into this
question but it's not so simple as all
that what what this is about
is
pardon the expression
a whole new world order okay that's an
expression that was trending yesterday
on twitter and it was trending because
an australian politician accidentally
let the phrase slip
back in place especially with reopening
and people going back to pubs and stuff
because our exposure sites still will
they be put back in place to be listed
once we are reopening because they're
not at the moment
we will be looking at what contact
tracing looks like in the new world
order and yes it will be pubs and clubs
and other things if we have a positive
case there our response may be
differently different if we know that
people are fully vaccinated so we're
working through a number of those
issues but we will have to reflect and
learn
the new world order i thought this was
15 days to slow the spread new world
order
because of the wuflu new world order is
a phrase you may have heard before
the the new world order was a term
popularized by george h.w bush in a
couple speeches that are now being
suppressed this was back at the start of
the first iraq war the gulf war
what is at stake
is more
than one small country
it is a big idea
a new world order
where diverse nations
are drawn together in common cause
to achieve the universal aspirations of
mankind peace
and security
freedom
and the rule of law
such is a world
worthy of our struggle
and worthy of our children's future we
have before us the opportunity to forge
for ourselves and for future generations
a new world order
a world where the rule of law
not the law of the jungle
governs the conduct of nations
when we are successful
and we will be we have a real chance at
this new world order
an order in which a credible united
nations
can use its peacekeeping role to fulfill
the promise and vision
of the un's founders
ah don't i don't know about that wait
the u.n is now going to just go in and
kind of run all these different
countries i don't know about that so
when i heard this australian politician
use the phrase new world order i said oh
where have i heard i heard that from
george bush let me look up that speech
so i look it up on youtube
and the speech won't come up
the clip won't come up actually what
comes up is some other speeches of
george bush and then
a uh a header like a little disclaimer
that says the new world order is a
conspiracy theory and it's not real and
it's to totally ignore this there's
nothing to see here pay no attention to
the man behind the curtain you say wait
what
n nothing says the new world order is a
conspiracy quite like burying the clips
of the speech of the new world order and
telling you it doesn't exist right
that's yeah okay
oh and having the largest corporation on
earth do that yeah that
that is my fears okay now i'm
but of course that's what this is i mean
that clip
was from september 11 1990 and january
16 1991 and bush was talking about the
gulf war and he's saying look what we're
going to do now the cold war is over
we're going to remake the entire world
in america's image and his son would
would pursue this path in the second
iraq war and the war on terror and and
abolishing tyranny in the world as he
said in the second inaugural and it was
a bit utopian and a bit progressive and
quite liberal and
but they really meant it they really
said we're there is going to be a world
order and we want to change the world
order and
the effect of the coronavirus lockdowns
without question is that
without quit i'm not saying it's some
sneaky cabal you know in the shadows
somewhere with space lasers or anything
i'm just saying
the effect of these lockdowns is to
reorder the way that citizens relate to
their nations and the way that nations
relate to the rest of the world that's
just without question i mean joe biden
proved it last night
by upending the constitutional order and
imposing this mandate
i'm so glad that you enjoyed that clip
you can get the whole show it's the
michael knowles show it's very easy to
remember because i'm michael knowles
that's the name of the show you can get
it at apple podcast but if i stitch your
google play wherever you get your
podcast head on over there right now get
your phone up
if you don't mind
pull up there you go pull up that app
type in the michael knowles show
subscribe
see you next time
[Music]
[Music]